- What do we got?
I have this
beautiful, handmade,
leather jacket with me today.
OK.
What do you know about it?
Not too much.
I just saw this little
label on the inside
when I was wearing
it, and I thought
it might be something special.
East West Musical
Instruments, San Francisco,
That's um, that's weird, It's
not a musical instrument.
[music playing]
I'm coming into
the shop, today,
to try to sell my
handmade, leather jacket.
This jacket is in
great condition.
It has all the fringes, and it
has a cute design on the back.
I'm hoping to sell the
jacket for $500 today,
but the lowest I'll
go is maybe like $100.
It's definitely cool.
Where did you get it?
I got it when I was
shopping in California,
at a thrift store.
Do you know how old it is?
I don't know how
old it is, but it
seems like it's been around.
It looks like
it's from the 60s.
I--
It's in great shape.
It's definitely
weird that it's
East West Musical Instruments.
I don't know much about that.
Normally I don't even really
mess with this kind of stuff.
What are you looking
to get out of it?
Maybe like $500.
OK.
This is kind of interesting
to me, this label right here.
Do you mind if I have a
friend of mine come in
and check it out?
- Yeah, of course.
All right, let
me give him a call.
Feel free to hang out.
I'll be back in a little bit.
Thank you.
To be perfectly
honest, I don't
know anything about this
East West label, inside
of this jacket.
And I would normally pass
on something like this,
but there's something
in my gut that's
telling me to find out more.
So I called in Jesse to see
if he knows anything about it.
I know it's not a
guitar or a instrument,
but I'm just kind
of curious if you
know anything about
this East West
Musical Instruments company.
Dude, this kind of cool.
They're actually
kind of famous, you
know, for making leather stuff
for rock stars back in the day.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
These jackets were made for,
like, the top rung rock star.
You know, it was a
$1,500, $1,600 jacket.
It was people like
Elvis Presley, Bruce
Springsteen, Janis Joplin.
It was people that
had a lot of money
to afford a job like this.
So, I mean, it
definitely sounds
like it's got a cool
history, but what's it worth?
You know, stuff like
this, because it's so rare,
and it's hard to find, you know,
a 46-year-old, 50-year-old,
piece of leather
that's in any kind
of condition to actually wear.
Anywhere from probably two to
three grand, believe it or not.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, it's not something
you see every day.
- Appreciate it, dude.
- No problem.
- Thanks for coming down, dude.
- Nice to meet you.
- Thank you.
- Cool jacket.
So you still want $500 for it?
Um, no.
Would you take $1,500 for it?
[music playing]
I don't know.
I'd rather keep it and, like,
pretend to be a rock star.
Will you do any more, maybe?
[music playing]
I'll do two grand.
That's the most I've ever
paid for a jacket, and it's--
[music playing]
Well I'll do two grand.
All right, cool.
Meet me over there.
We gotta do some paperwork.
All right, sweet.
I settled on $2,000, which is
a lot more than I had planned,
so I'm very, very
happy about it.